tip that middle class famous tour is a
cooking this thing's selling itself but
just in case we're gonna hit you with it
right now gang do yourself a favor stand
up comedy show then we played a little
ayg with the crowd grab the squad come
out and see us great way to introduce
two people to the show it's a super
super fun time I promise you yeah gang
coming up in November we got two hot
shows down there and hot Atlanta is part
of the red clay Comedy Festival you get
individual tickets for that or tickets
to the whole Fest yourself then the next
night we're banging over there to
Charlotte North Carolina yeah North
Carolina South Carolina get them tickets
if you're close because we're gonna see
that's the last time we're coming this
year I know we got two sold out ones in
Philly you snooze you lose we added one
in Providence Rhode Island in December
get those tickets and we added another
one in Boston as well get those tickets
because those are going to sell out
they're selling grab them we're telling
you right now come see us see you there
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite of comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage isn't it little shall
we sit there with your favorite
comedians and we find that they grow to
be classy yeah so to just a big old
piece of trash I'm your host Dave
trolley coming at you on a beautiful day
we're down here at antuti's basement
unfortunately she just hit by a car okay
which was parked okay my co-host is
coming at you from right next to me he
is the CEO of Ru garbage he's an
international businessman he is not to
be trifled with in the boardroom or the
bedroom give it up for KJ Kevin James
Ryan
hey thanks for tuning in as always just
make sure your review subscribe on
iTunes full video available on YouTube
and as you know new guy Luke don't
launches through the roof there you go
oh my God thank you we're talking about
a try hard Toby come back T-Bone you're
killing me uh and then obviously the
greatest goddamn website of all time uh
www.patreon.com are you garbage check it
the [ __ ] out it's a party over there
damn love that money and gang as you
know Tebow McMuffin is ill he's sick uh
a little cold little Sniffles the flu
whatever he's got Corona it's got
covered it's not asking questions I know
yeah Toby's got a hot case of [ __ ]
Delta I'll tell you that well we got new
guy Luke filming and he's a good looking
kid a little stupid not gonna lie but
wait Harry dude your chest hair is wild
yeah get a pick up there he's nervous on
the bike a lot
my first time this is your first time
ever talking into a microphone because
your first time in public to be honest
with you yeah first time ever talking to
my wife I mean yeah maybe like uh Middle
School like uh like Auditorium something
like that you never did karaoke or
anything like that Caribbean we're not
counting that right
I'm a showman I mean give me he starts
doing Hall and Oates give me a dozen Bud
Lights yeah Gang new guy Luke ladies and
gentlemen
we love you pal
um gang let me tell you something right
now got a hot show ahead of us here huh
could not be more excited that we're
incredible and I mean incredibly special
guests here with us today
and old pal I tell them all the time
he's one of my favorites he killed when
we do shows together in the city I stay
and I watch them I get a nice giggle I
love this guy to death he's a very funny
stand-up comedian and actor you've seen
him in but not limited to Super Troopers
I'll end up with John Noor you got The
Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon about
that the Late Show Stephen Colbert has a
2020 special out called Grand K stupid
jokes and I'll tell you this right now
here's the turkey what's that if you go
over to that use tube right now
youtube.com slash Grand K comedy you can
check out his brand new amazing special
Grand K live in a bowling alley do me a
favor give it up Grand K everybody
that's me that is a great intro thanks
Pat I felt good about myself I meant
that I tell you that I've always before
we even like really good friends
he he kills me I stand there and I watch
this
I know he's a [ __ ]
he's my speed man the kid's just funny I
don't know what to tell you I'd always
give him a cookie and say yeah okay
thank you thank you
thank you so much I think obviously
you're both very funny buddy thank you
so much thank you for coming and staying
with us congratulations on the special
thank you what is the back story of
Graham K we know you're a Canadian
Feller you're a real Hoser
that's a that's a slur holy eggs
I only come from a whole family of
hosers too there is a Canadian people
have been through enough and come here
there is a mild American slur that's
very very uh that really pisses people
off in Canada I can't remember exactly
what it was it's something like
douchebag or something you know what I'm
talking about the American slur for
Canadians no no no well we call you no
no there's a all right hold on that's
harmless down here but up there it's
like it's what they call in jail they
call pedophiles or something oh goof
goof yeah yeah you're goofy or this
guy's a real goof it's like whoa It's
like yeah [ __ ] that is I didn't
they'll suffocate you in a bag of milk
up there perfect I didn't really know
like I you know people don't people like
like hockey players they like if you
call somebody a goofy hockey players
have their own vernacular they do I had
a nice time he's got a nice head of
lettuce buddy tarps off let's go that
means take your shirt off
we're doing that for a patreon episode
we're just gonna go through all the
[ __ ] they were hot Canadian [ __ ]
tune you up right now
it's all right you're [ __ ] done Bud
Mitch absolutely ruin you
um I I wouldn't but uh not me but a guy
I was in one hockey fight growing up I
field I got I got sent to uh she was big
though
she was the coach okay
she was a big I went for the biggest one
when I let me tell you you grab the
biggest one you own the litter when I
found out that men played field hockey
in other parts of the world I was like
God damn that's why my uh wife's whole
family real they're all the everybody
played that's what they played
all their friends I don't know if they
were the skirts all their friends are
like that's where they all
[Laughter]
Graham give us the back story baby where
you from
I was I'm from Ottawa Ottawa Canada
specifically guy represented we're gonna
have a great year there you go did you
get more wrinkles
yeah iron that with an egg beater
went a Corvette last night it's not a
good system to what you do is you you
wash your clothes and then you uh you
get distracted or you you lazy you run
out of time yeah of course yeah see when
when you hustle like me when you're
always on the grind sure you run out of
time and uh I you know I guess this was
in the drawer I figured by the time
that's why that made it to the drawer
yeah I forgot I was on the corner of the
bed I get it yeah not good because you
don't do you have a unit in the
apartment
do you have a washer and dryer yes you
do wait when you're in the basement okay
yeah yeah because okay so you got to go
down to the basement I do this I walk to
the laundromat next door yeah you wash
them you dry them then you just throw
them in the bag and you bring them
upstairs you got to get to them in like
two seconds what if you're grinding yeah
if you're out there grinding garyvee
don't have time to fold clothes yeah
no I'm from Ottawa
this guy's a professional he don't have
Ty's grinding I gotta get I gotta get
this over with so we can get to the next
segment I got three minutes I got a
commercial break I got specials to move
let's go I'm not here to talk about my
goddamn laundry
yeah it's the uh you know there's just
there's no fluff and fold sure fluff
yeah I I understand I understand jamming
in the Ikea bag so you don't fold it in
the in the laundry mat I would assume I
bring it up uh and I leave it I usually
try and fold it but sometimes you know
there's I got stuff sure you got stuff
going on you know I gotta go to bed I
gotta I gotta go to bed yeah I hate it
man I hate find the laundry I hit it
quick crazy I just know that two hours
or whatever is gonna [ __ ] suck and
that's just what I do yeah it's tough
you're good all right back to Ottawa but
anyway uh Mom Dad brother sisters laying
on us I got uh I got a dad I got a mom
okay okay you I got a brother and uh he
has autism okay I'm gonna take care of
him a lot growing up my older or younger
he's younger younger years younger
verbal non-verbal
um verbal but he's you know 36 now and
he has a uh you know he he he's like a
five-year-old or six-year-old gotcha
like he sent yesterday he sent a um
picture to everybody
um don't make me laugh at this whatever
it's gonna be that the tension is crazy
like he said oh my god he has an email
list if you get on the email list you're
on you're just on it you can't get off
it uh is that true yeah one lady one
lady one lady one lady has to get off
she signed up a special needs program
was like get me off this email list and
he was like you don't you don't talk to
me that way he called her a damn blasted
woman ah and I was like where do you get
damn I think it's because he just he
from Deadwood no I think you do I think
that's you get those your insults if you
only Watch Inspector Gadget
you know I'm with you anyway he sent a
picture
of uh of a toothbrush uh that he got 94
people
we don't even have 94 people on our team
yeah he's good he's good he collects
them and he does you are on there's no
MailChimp unsubscribed I love that and
he one time so he so Greg Stone I'm very
familiar previous yes Greg Stone's on it
Greg Stone gave him some uh Spider-Man
figurines and so you know he's on the
he's on email this can't get up
um and he sent him he's a lifetime
member
you know and um
and I saw this like group email and I
was like with a picture and I was like
people are always trying to you know
he's like you know what sir Peter let me
click on it and it was just a picture of
him making a grilled cheese sandwich I
think that'll brighten up he was like
mess is all right
that's pretty good you know what I mean
what am I all what am I upset about this
is a grown man a grilled cheese sandwich
I love it take a pic of this does he
still live with your mom and dad uh they
uh all my all of their extra like all
their savings or not they're out there
but all my like inheritance they used to
to buy him a one bedroom apartment and
uh which is fine this way it should be
um
right now
I I this is did they sit down and tell
you that like Hey listen they did they
did but this is in my app but I I'm I I
have like a newer joke about it where
I'm like because this is new this isn't
in my left my newest special but
whatever they said they sat me down
there like we this you know you're gonna
have nothing but we don't he can't be on
the streets so that's the way it is but
he has his own one bedroom apartment I
have my and he's still like
he can't count and we're like trying to
get him to like he lost his job in the
pandemic and what are you doing uh he
was like a part-time janitor just to
like keep him busy or whatever and we I
would like I I would he started drinking
more I'm trying to figure out like how
like how much is he really ain't
shrinking yeah he goes to the store all
right grilled cheese and Brews
he's got an ID
he's 36 years old
this guy's got a a bang an email yes
yeah he's eating grilled cheeses he's
got a new toothbrush and he's drinking a
couple of bats he's drinking he drinks
the Bat Blue because Blue's his favorite
color that's true we call him big
Tasties and uh
he's like
I'm trying to figure out like how many
beers he had any and any and but he
can't count so it's hard for me to ask
him like about how many beers you have
he's like buddy he gets angry at me when
I ask him questions
what the [ __ ] you doing he talks to me
like an idiot sometimes when he knows I
know the answer so like how many beers
do you have and he goes uh uh Graham I
can't count yeah like yeah yeah you
idiot which is like a weird sentence to
hear I can't count you stupid idiot
you're like I am an idiot you're right I
knew the answer
anyway so he's entitled because like
I'll I'll be he'll be like
um you know why don't you live in your
own one bedroom apartment he says that
to you to me yeah he's a poor
[ __ ]
you get your [ __ ] get your [ __ ]
together and lose the roommate get a job
working a wrinkled shirt back to
Brooklyn right or everybody his his [ __ ]
is folded that is true
um
dude the fact that he's he's throwing
Shady to you he does his my favorite
this guy's all right get your [ __ ]
together get a get a get a job being a
janitor six hours a week
get your own one bedroom apartment and
uh and I was like he's like why don't
you have your grandma he always ask me
like why don't you have your own one
bedroom apartment sure you know I had
roommates until I was this guy's 37
years old I had roommates and I'll be
like buddy I can't have my own one
manageable apartment so expensive
because I can count yeah yeah
that's really jamming me up big time
anyway is he close to your is he close
nearby here where your parents are he
lives close to them now uh does he ever
get in trouble with the booze like he
just drinks in his apartment he goes to
bed he doesn't ever like get in there
are the only trying trouble he gets in
is during family reunions he gets pretty
good Scott are you talking about he's
out there [ __ ] owning everybody what
are you talking about
one time he was like you live with a
roommate yeah they're my kids yeah
whatever
Uncle Steve come get me Infinity beers
in the family reunion I have before I
forget what is like give a ballpark of
the number of beers he's doing like a
six year well here's the thing can you
put him down is he a big dude my yeah
he's a big dude he's he's a big dude
he's uh as tall as you he's a couple
you're a brick [ __ ] house big guy he's
my brother is probably 20 pounds more
than me okay and uh but he he's like
you know what my grilled cheeses they're
not that good they burn
yeah nice grilled cheese yeah yeah
anyway so he he's like um my buddy who
uh my buddy from high school like uh
they he takes him out my two best
friends from high school take him out
for lunch every now and again
and uh they were like yeah
my buddy Mike was like
uh so how many he's like yeah return
them all my cans and I got money and
he's like how much money did you get and
he was like he was like twelve dollars
dear God it's like 400 meters so many
so many beers
yeah this guy's the drinking champ in
Canada I don't even know it so you know
but he now he's not drinking on the
weekdays that's good
um progress me too actually yeah that's
a similar movement so he's cool with
that he knows he knows not to drink
during the week he does say you know
Graham sometimes we just forget
sure what day it is sure bogged down
with these details you're out here
grinding yeah he's out there yeah
sometimes Wednesday is the weekend
but uh uh yeah anyway you go to Family
Reunion and uh and some once sometime he
would like uh he would one one year he
when did these take place by the way and
where is it your business at Janet's
house Thanksgiving yeah idiot of course
that's not a family reunion that's
Thanksgiving no
oh yeah whatever family get together and
uh he was just like uh I think he was
like uh
tickling everyone's girlfriend or wife
and then giving Wet Willies to the
boyfriend
and uh
yeah
so you sound like your brother's awesome
yeah it is it is I imagine tickling a
dude's girlfriend giving him away
[Laughter]
in a great way the most disrespectful
[ __ ] I've ever had yeah and but everyone
kind of just takes it because everyone
grew up with them but we're kind of like
but the women are uncomfortable so you
have to you have to kind of you have to
kind of and also he rides the bus you
don't know what's going on on the bus
you know we we taught my dad one time my
dad took him to Florida
Canadian [ __ ] going around giving every
Everybody
my dad had to buy him uh big sunglasses
because he was creeping everyone out at
the beach
my dad was like we're trying to teach my
dad was trying to teach him to side eye
okay you're dead he's like you can't
wait my dad doesn't like that never
showed me how to be a creeper on a
Florida beach what here's the thing my
dad is a he's like he doesn't want him
to get arrested or beat up of course
which he can't he very easily get beat
up and arrested and he also know like
it's a behavior you're not going to
change you kind of have to try to yeah
you have to modify it a little bit you
know if you tell him like Hey you can't
look at yeah the ladies on the beach
it's not probably gonna process do it
this way a little totally it's super
hilarious and then you're like oh he
could get he could get messed up pretty
bad and um and yeah and he won't know
what's going on which is you know but
running like that that's why I asked you
how he is with with the boozing yeah
exactly so it's anyway it's a whole
thing but he my dad bought him his
glasses because he was teaching in the
side eye he's like okay look you can't
stare okay exactly you know people are
getting creeped out because like what
you just you scare you stare for it but
you move your eyes everybody like okay
you do that and then just
like
uh 1970s
like cataract poker player yeah that's
fine yeah what he should do is get on
the ones with the mirror with the
mirrors and the thing so he can really
creep got a 360. yeah
all right oh man all right your brother
sounds awesome he's the best he's he's
the man for sure so he's younger yeah
what'd your mom and dad do growing up my
mom uh so here's the thing I don't think
I'm gonna make the cut for being uh
garbage okay uh well I'll I will
determine all right that's fair okay so
we grew up by when my uh we were like
lower more just middle class and my mom
worked at the Canadian Post Office okay
uh in the in the head office and
um my head office in your town or the
head office for the country yeah and uh
so my dad was uh he sold computer uh
software software they traveled like
town to town and at one point he uh
lived in Montreal which is two hours
away he like spent Monday to Friday
there because he tried to start like a a
Best Buy style computer store okay but
with like the uh but the problem is he
needed the the in order to get the
funding from the bank he needed to get
like in partnership with uh a rich
family like one of the richest families
in Canada the people who made make like
Crown Royal and um
yeah and uh Canadian Club whiskey right
yeah you know what I like I like that
Helix mattress I love that Helix
mattress oh Felix you know who else
likes the Helix mattress the Foley
family really because I got the
sister-in-law to make a purchase for the
little one there you go she's like
what's the name of that company that you
would that you know the greatest [ __ ]
mattress company of all [ __ ] that's
what I told I'm talking Helix I told her
go on a website take the quiz see what
the kid likes to sleep in see how it
goes you sleep hot you sleep cold they
even got matches for the big boys like
us you take the quiz they match up with
a mattress that's perfect for you baby
promo code garbage I was matched up with
the old uh Twilight series love that
king size mattress jerked off in it that
ain't no big deal king size mattress
small size penis oh that's supposed to
mean no you say that
it looks smaller in the kitchen I know I
mean what do you expect in a twin I'm
home I know I'm a porn star and a twin
are you getting that Helix Helix big boy
yeah tiny coming in um Helix is offering
up to 200 math 200 hold on Helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders look at two free pillows for our
listeners go to hillsleep.com Garbage
Guys I'm telling you it's the best sleep
of your life be a grown-up get a nice
mattress they got uh easy payment
options it ships right to your door for
free if you don't like it you send it
right back they take care of you he
looks sleep.com slash garbage healing
with Helix better sleep starts now do it
do it okay let's talk about Adam and Eve
let's talk about honey undo my belt real
quick
let's talk about naughty naughty times
whether you're with somebody or Along on
Adam and Eve has got you covered let me
tell you something you go out you take
some bird out on a date you got dinner
you got this you got that just get a
[ __ ] huge dildo and go home and have
a good time I'm talking about I said it
once I'll say it again if you're looking
to put your little pecker in something
hit up an Adam and Eve or if you're a
guy or a girl who wants to put some in
you they also got that too yeah good
stuff uh baby it's all packaging into
discrete it doesn't come from
www.bonerville or anything like that
your neighbors aren't gonna know you're
a freak only you and your partner or
just you and the dog whatever you guys
do the cat might not talk to you that
dress in a week I'm telling you guys uh
they have an amazing offer the good
folks of Adam and Eve have been
supporting podcasts for a long time last
day of supporting us we love them baby
so get something have a little fun spice
things up sitting in your house it's
about to be winter time you're gonna be
it gets dark early shove something in
your I'm sitting on one right now
select anyone out of and use code
garbage this is an exclusive offer so be
sure to tell him kipi sent you
but he using Code garbage they get 50
off and free shipping go to
adamandeve.com right now doing yeah yeah
and uh anyway so
but they he had to get the the he had he
had the dumbest son
the dumbest son was left like he was
like a cokehead sure and uh easiest ones
to get to yeah yeah and anyway the guy
like how did your dad meet this guy I
don't know did uh did a bunch of blow
and like ruined the the business the guy
did or yeah the guy did and my dad went
bankrupt and then um wait so he
partnered with him he got the money they
opened the store and it went down it
went under yeah yeah yeah he opened it
in Montreal yeah it was like a bigger
city but it was close I thought it was
like it was like too small at the time
okay and um and uh yeah my mom uh Rose
through the ranks of the Canadian Post
Office my dad ended up rebounding and
like becoming a computer consultant he
was like a computer nerd pimp gotcha
you'd come to him and he'd be like I got
the right nerd for you and yeah yeah
that's pretty smart yeah Amazon yeah
yeah yeah yeah and my mom Rose through
the ranks of the Canadian post office
until she was uh one step below vice
president
that happened when I was like
19 18 19. yeah and we were like you know
so growing up we like moved was that a
big influx of Cash when she got that job
that's like for sure same thing with my
parents my mom started doing oh really
good at her job when I was like 19 or 20
she yeah she was she was an office
manager of a of an office and then that
people that she worked for bought the
building and she became like the sea oh
yeah CFO of the building was doing real
well nice didn't [ __ ] help me any
yeah I was like
I was like out yeah yeah they was they
started doing better and then they uh I
was really bad at school and then they
sent me to boot camp for the last two
years of high school that's a first well
they thought I had obsessed or they
thought I had I was on drugs
but I I had a weirdo I just had
obsessive compulsive disorder so I was
you on drugs as well no no drugs I did I
mean I bought weed like maybe twice okay
and I uh I just was touching everything
three times I was four okay four yeah
yeah and I I like for some reason I like
three because if you had uh my thing was
like they had an impure thought like if
you sat down you had like a you thought
about Michael Jordan or whatever but if
you thought about like a murderer you
saw on the news sure like a homeless man
with scabs that you saw on the way to
wherever you were uh I was like oh my
I'm gonna [ __ ] it you know it's crazy
but you're like that's the crazy thing
about OCD you know is like you know it's
crazy but you can't help and I was like
oh my face is gonna change into that
homeless guy with a scab on his face so
I gotta sit two more times because that
will on that'll outweigh the tainted
first one and so and if the on the third
time if I did it wrong I have to do it
nine times so everything by the time's
three three times three mine is 16. oh
hilarious yeah yeah yeah I knocked my
head I knock my head three times and
then I have to go chew my hair and then
knock three more times and if I mess
that up I have to do the whole thing
over again wow yeah you still do that
I'm going to wackoville yeah yeah yeah
yeah are you [ __ ] lunatics
your brother's watching this on his
couch laughing at us yeah but there was
no OCD back then and it was like they
were like are you on drugs and I didn't
want to you know you're like whatever I
was 15 16 I didn't want to be like well
actually uh I think he's gonna kill me I
think my face is going to change into a
killer I saw on the news so I it was
like way cooler to say yeah I'm on I'm
on I'm on drugs
writ large drugs yeah I do them all baby
and then I got sent to uh Saskatchewan
for two years which is far away it's
like it was like it's a fly there so you
said you told your parents you were on
drugs when you weren't I was not on
drugs I said it three times I'm on drugs
I'm on drugs I'm on drugs that's pretty
wild
uh no did they ask you what drugs you
were doing no they just said drugs one
time I was I lit a match my parents are
crazy they're great people but they're
crazy like we would we would get kicked
out of restaurants and stuff
what are you talking about where are you
coming in
the garbage
got in bed with a cokehead and went
bankrupt getting kicked out of
restaurants you went to boot camp your
brother's awesome you're doing fake
drugs and you went to boot camp one time
I lit a match in my room just because I
don't know I was a kid I was like a
teenager and it's like before I got sent
my mom ran and it was like are you
sniffing the matches I was like
did they grow up under a rock I don't
know what's going on that they're so
yeah my mom my mom grew up she's a
refugee from Slovakia and so they she
just doesn't know a lot uh Slovakia
there's a big bad sniffing problem yeah
yeah I am I will say that yeah so uh you
know she she uh yeah she she just was
like Notch I don't know I got you and
then um was the boot camp like a high
school too it was a high school yeah was
it military it's that wasn't military
it's technically not a boot camp it's
but it's the cheapest boarding school in
North America
yeah your your teachers could hit you uh
I got caught uh trying to buy booze from
a a girl came like came from the that
was the year prior and was like free and
came with a car and I was like can you
go the next town to buy us like just a
like we call him a Mickey like a little
like whatever 16 ouncer and then uh she
came back with 24 beers I was like what
how am I gonna hide 24 beers anyway I
got caught and
um and I had to do guard this is a town
of 300 in Saskatchewan in the winter
uh and I had to do the trash collection
for the town I have to wake up at five
in the morning and it was like minus 40.
[ __ ] that and uh and then if you and if
you didn't make your bed a bunch you'd
get to maripo points if you collect
enough to Bear points at the end of the
week everyone with like too many demerit
points would have to go to a room and do
burpees uh until someone puked
and I was just like click click
I want to ask how the senior talent show
did they ever hit you actually hit you
uh no no they didn't no okay no I go up
there and kick their ass for you yeah
yeah at my grandkid
good kid did it get did it get too sad
no no did I make it you guys are just
collecting right now yeah just process
yeah figuring it out garbage it's a lot
so far so far it's all yeah it's always
the people too are like I'm not gonna be
guarded
yeah crazy did you go to college I did
yeah yeah graduate I did yeah good good
student would you major college yeah I I
got into college I had pretty bad grades
well did this place turn you around
so it didn't help you with the OCD
obviously well here's the thing I think
it did okay but inadvertently uh well
because other I would have to fight
other students you would you were
fighting up there well because they're
like they're like mean to you if you
show weakness or whatever and I'm
clicking and clacking and every time
someone hits you in the face and you
gotta fight like hit me two more times
I'm a really good yeah I'm gonna get
hard and then we'll see what happens
first I'll get hard
anyway uh they they uh yeah so it's like
you you know it's just very awkward
you're trying to fit in you got you
you're in a room with
um with four other guys there's five
people to a room and uh Hell in a Cell
the room is like this size you know
and uh so you're like
it's just hard so I I basically figured
if I could dig myself out like if my
brain could dig myself into a hole
I could dig myself
out of a hole I just had to do a
piecemeal like I remember it getting
worse and worse and worse I was like I
could make it better and better and it's
also like when you're I think it's you
know for me it was like very easy to do
when I was living at home and in control
of a lot of things when you know it's
like but
when I moved away to college I like had
to break because I'm like I'm living
with four other people in a house where
like I don't I can't control everything
and they're like yeah yeah start going
like all right maybe I just won't do it
on this like I don't know I didn't do it
that time this way or whatever and then
like yeah yeah it's like incremental for
sure I also think that you know by the
time I was out of that high school
um I was 19. back then in Canada where I
was from a little overdone you do uh you
did five years in high school I'm from
Irving a nickel I'm from Ontario and for
like
25 30 years
uh it was five years of high school and
but I got sent to Saskatchewan so like a
year older than everybody at the end
where they had like normal four years
and so anyway I my point is is I think
that
right because you were in college at
that time I was in high school but we
were both just like 19 when it started
to descend it's like our hormones were
calming down you know what I mean yeah
gotcha yeah gotcha and also we don't
want to get made fun of and yeah it's
like you know you're trying to [ __ ]
you're trying to nail abroad you can't
[ __ ] squeeze my ween through it yeah
yeah you went five do it 16 now what was
that you can't make it to 16. I could
never make it what was the Japanese do
for being honest yeah what was the
jacking off situation in the room with
four with four other people they called
it a beat sheet you always the old boys
means you've been there at least a year
prior you get the bottom bunk and the
bottom bunk was key so you could hang a
sheet from the top punk it was called a
beat sheet they knew what you were doing
in there well yeah you have to yeah we
called it the beat sheet if you put up
the beat sheet you know what's going on
down down there put your headphones on
and go to sleep and then there was the
smallest or newest or kid would uh got
like a bed coming out of the middle of
one of the bunk beds he was the fifth it
had drawers underneath it and that was
the penis bed because it looked like a
little dick coming out of the two bones
and then you could not jack off off the
on the penis pit how was the food at
that place uh Michelin star yeah yeah I
mean not great it was like you know I I
don't know it was like cafeteria food
okay yeah but it was like we ate a lot I
ate a lot I didn't know what to do so I
just worked out every day I gained 50
pounds in two years there you go and I
got into a better University because I
played uh football Canadian football
which is the same history dance and uh
and then I would then by the time I got
in I was like I was lucky because then I
was like my brain was a little more
normal and I could you know get decent
grades did you play football all four
years at school no I tore my hip okay
flexor uh and I'm actually getting and
it's been a problem ever since and I'm
getting surgery November 10th check that
out folks check it out on Instagram
you'll be live streaming that yeah I'm
getting uh open penis surgery
November 10th okay
um hmm uh yeah so yeah okay yeah the
house that you grew up in single family
home but you guys had your own yeah yeah
we grew up they bought a place downtown
back when like no one was buying stuff
downtown in like the early 80s and uh
but it was great it was a great place to
grow up we had like a block with like a
bunch of kids my age we had block
parties nice we would like you know we
we hated the other street block over it
was like very diverse like there was
like you guys do pools up there not at
downtown there's not enough room but we
have like city pools we'd go to okay
yeah all right garage we had a garage we
shared a driveway but we had we both had
separate garages I always wanted that I
thought it was like building friends a
little bit it was nice hey what are you
doing in the courtyard yeah Matt Hoy
lived uh Next Door Man up to Maddie we'd
always our dads my dad would always send
me out first to shovel
in the winter and then Matt then Matt
hoy's dad would be like
God Graham's out there yeah grams out
there you get out there you get out
there and shovel that had to be brutal
what are we talking India yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it was brutal well Canadian
like Ottawa winter specifically is like
Ottawa is a very weird place I I would
like to see is some sort of graph I
think it's like the crazy it's like 90
degrees in the summer uh and then minus
30 in the winter it's just like boom
boom and then it's just there's so much
snow how many feet are we talking like
one good snowfall you got to go out
there and shovel I like you and Matt you
get a foot you get a foot and you hope
it's fluffy yeah different types of snow
yeah things with that like up there and
like the mission it's like it snows it's
like a foot and then like 10 days later
it's like a foot and then yeah and it's
like it just compounds yeah you can't
you can't and the driveway is long
I could it went full it wasn't like in
the front it was like a driveway that
with like the whole length of the houses
and then split off at the end oh man
that's brutal what kind of cars were
talking about was a family car girl
would you whip around in grew up we went
we started my my parents
we had two sobs that when I was born and
they had they were rust Bubbles and uh
what's a rust bubble like the bubbling
rust and then I would always poke them
and my my mom would be like stop poking
the car stop poking her did they buy
them new
um I'm I think so but they were old like
they had like I think they had like more
money and then then I then we were born
and they had no money because this is
probably what this is late 80s early 90s
early 80s and like mid 80s and then they
ran out of money and then we went we
went from two because sobs were nice
back then they were nice they're nice
they were sharp yeah good cars I don't
know anybody that drives one now no well
they stop making it but they they did
they get a yellow one and a blue one and
then um
a bunch of rust Bubbles and uh our dog
Bruno ate the radio so there's doing
some wires down there oh my God you're
not garbage at all
[Laughter]
you also had more responses than I've
never heard in my life gently you told
your instructor at boot camp and my dog
at my radio
but then we had we had uh then we had a
we went from that to a Mercury Sable
station wagon and they bought a used
Honda Civic
and then very very 80s 90s cars yeah
yeah and the Mercury Sable station wagon
was a lemon and I remember on a family
uh that was kind of the rounded one a
little bit right it was before that okay
but it was it was the fourth tour it was
the fancy Ford Taurus I think it had
like I was a Ford Taurus kid bro
electric chair like Windows and chairs
and it had a just a slightly different
uh Grille it was like the grill
illuminated it didn't have metal slash
but it was the same car and it had a
rumble seat in the back what's a rumble
seat it's uh the backward facing seat
yeah in the very back can I ask you this
about your children will die if they get
rear-ended sure can I ask you this about
the sobs with a two-door or four-door
one was two door one was four-door
two-door cars has a family car weird
though every time Mike we had were you
trying to get laid Yeah I feel like a
nine-year-old and your dad's like all
right come back here yeah can you get in
or whatever yeah yeah I hated it put
your hand on his shoulder it's [ __ ]
weird it goes like this it's like a
triangle at the bottom that kid that
wasn't easy no I sat in one as an adult
and I'm like I'm never [ __ ] doing
this again yeah yeah
no way yeah bro I was a little bit
thinner but it was still scary yeah
you're like it's Sputnik yeah that's
hilarious
[Laughter]
that car the Mercury Sable blew up on a
family trip but my dad where was the
trip we were going to Quebec City we're
back to the gills with and then the
Piston shot through the his kid shot
through his trash he stinks he's Bonkers
I just remember it it's the the front
the the front hood would and a bunch of
smoke came out and my dad went Jesus
Christ
was he driving yeah we're going fast
engine exploded
[Laughter]
yeah like pulling tubes gang sure we all
do but doesn't it suck when you start
hacking up along because the smoke is so
hot you look like a bummer Gummer in
front of all the kids also they start
thinking you're a cop they get you
jammed up next thing you know you got a
gun to the back of your head and you're
tied up in the trunk
but with freeze pipe it cools the smoke
down with freeze pipe it'll save your
life could save your life not that's not
patent pending or not and I'm just
saying it good cools the smoke down it's
really cool man they have a unique
design you throw it in the fridge
guys pipes bubblers bongs dab rigs more
whatever you're smoking these boys got
it all right so if you're coming [ __ ]
come correct with a freeze pipe I hear a
bubbler stupendous yeah I put a little
uh tobacco in there obviously so head
over to freezepipe.com and enjoy the new
favorite piece at everyday great prices
you could use code garbage for 10 off
your next order
that's the t-h-e-freeze pipe.com use
code garbage 10 shop today your throat
and lungs will thank you now back to the
show
but they always say my parents where I'm
glad we bought the extended warranty I
almost didn't Canadians are big warranty
people like we love the warranty a lot
of insurance free healthcare we'll have
a good extended warranty now you go to
Quebec City on a family vacation this is
the summer I assume oh yeah what do you
do down there with pouring rain I
remember fire on my car at least
saved Our lives our goddamn lives
uh what do you do there you walk around
and you can see it it's a city there's
no like beach or there's no like there
it's like a European city it was founded
in like 1500 or something like that so
it's like a yeah it's got old buildings
it looks like Europe down Cobblestone
and they speak in most of Quebec speaks
like very dirty French like it's like
Alabama to London you know what I mean
and but Quebec City has like the more
refined like they're they're very little
snooty they find out you're from English
Canada they're like they won't even they
don't speak any English even though they
probably know a few words and they're
how do you go walk around look at stuff
and um you stay in a hotel soak in the
culture oh this is a connection what
happened was is I go they're like you're
gonna go back for a second year to boot
camp and we're walking around the
cobblestones Quebec City I'm like I'm
not going back
come on I'll go live with Aiden and I'll
work at a grocery store or I'll figure
it out you know I'm not gonna go back
I'm gonna move out and uh and then they
just kept working me working me working
me and I knew I didn't want to like
sleep on Aiden's couch he's just a guy
who's 19 and living with his older
brother and they were smoking a bunch of
weed and I was like I knew it was a bad
bad lie bad Vibe for me
um and then uh anyway so
they were like
you know there's like I always wanted a
tri-color Montreal Expos hat fitted and
uh there was one in the store Quebec
City Montreal same Province you know and
I was like all right if you buy me that
hat I'll go back and uh a cheap date I
should have gotten I should have
bargained for more yeah yes yeah got the
whole uniform at least yeah well I knew
I knew they wouldn't give me anything
more where would you stay when you go to
the Quebec are you stay in a hotel
yeah I stay in a hotel one room the
whole family uh two beds yeah I think we
would do we would do like a a hotel or a
motel with two rooms adjoining yeah one
time we watched always it was a rainy
day and we watched Braveheart and during
the sex scene because we were in one
room my my dad made me no maybe maybe
do what you got to do you do your sin
behind there and when you're finished
you come back out and you finish the
film yeah uh no he made me go to the
bathroom
and like wait till the sex scene was
over because it was what sex scenes in
Braveheart there's like nothing I I
don't know there might be some sides
I've never seen it he doesn't know he
was in a [ __ ]
half hard staring at myself in the
mirror Mel Gibson really giving a tour
Come On Pop tell me pop please I'm
halfway there for God's sakes
why did you think
crazy crazy I don't know that's the
taunted cars episode and everyone's dead
you got a grade on a curve but I mean
you're not too shabby did you ever come
down to the States for a vacation or
anything like that yeah we go to Vermont
and I'd be I remember one time crying
because I was gonna feel is just Canada
we would go for uh the most Canadian of
the states we go to Vermont go to Maine
we go to sideways it's like Mexico to
you one time we went to uh Smuggler's
Notch in New Hampshire
look out of a book
I was scared 40 degrees it's roasting
down here
I'm I was so scared I was gonna get shot
shot
I remember my parents said when we
crossed like I was like there's guns in
America there's gangs everywhere in
Vermont Americans love their guns their
own maniacs and I was scared I was gonna
get shot on the streets of Stowe or
Smuggler's Notch Vermont
[Laughter]
I can't dude that's all right yeah
wrote a window up Ma you're gonna get
this all clipped
oh yeah I loved it I could get I was
allowed to have uh soda I could get an
Orangina and uh they gave me 50 bucks I
could buy and I bought I could buy Lego
sick how old were you dude it's 22.
I had an orange Gina and Legos you can
get this kid to do anything
we didn't have a like they wouldn't give
us anything in his defense those things
are all pretty awesome and orangine is
fantastic 50 bucks would go far in the
Lego castle Lego we're talking like did
you not have like 1992 Castle Lego did
you not have Legos in Canada yeah we had
Legos but you wouldn't allowed to get
them well it wasn't a family trip yeah
it wasn't special yeah
you're at the board do you have anything
to declare I got my Legos I got my Legos
all right you mentioned you make sure
this weird kid doesn't talk anymore
um we are not allowed to drink soda
growing up
uh no we would do uh on the weekend my
we were allowed but my I'd be like Mom
we might get Coca-Cola or Pepsi please
and then she'd come back every time with
diet caffeine free you know the gold one
and I'd be like you and she like she oh
I made a mistake again I'd be like Mom
just so you know do you want the red one
and then same time same thing oh I made
a mistake again I was so stupid it
lasted like two years kind of pitched
though that was all right
yeah I'd get your head up I thought it
was a health drink compared to the
regular so I was [ __ ] I was I felt
like a power lifter
like what is it diet caffeine free just
brown Water Jackson Mississippi Water oh
God would you pack your lunch to school
uh yeah funny thing about that one time
my mom she just you know when a potato
just grows a bunch of stuff out of it an
old potato the eyes yes it grows ears
and you're not supposed to eat those
right well one day she just put that in
my container and nothing else just as a
joke and I opened up at lunch time in
front of everybody they had like their
sandwiches and I had one potato with a
bunch of stuff coming out of it and then
what no there's the joke is you but then
you also don't have a lunch I got a I
was like sad and then I got a call from
the principal's office and my mom bought
me McDonald's
ah there you go yeah she got my ass took
the burger patty out and gave you a Diet
Coke yeah yeah
uh what were their pets like growing up
we got a we had uh Bruno who ate the
radio we used to try and ride him like a
horse sure and we had a he kept him on a
leash in the back and then uh he used to
barking on the winner too
um not as not for very long but uh he'd
go out there and uh do you have a dog
cast
no but we uh you know dogs uh we you
know in Canada we they don't know dogs
wear coats we just walk them around
their dogs the 90s was different too
yeah 90s with doll there's minus 40.
he's out there absolutely he's got a he
loves it you jump in the snow and they
you know they they get extra you know
hair what kind of dog was it Irish
Setter
and then if you're like Chihuahua
Chihuahua
except they're frozen they jump in the
snow I couldn't find them
you go down to the oh okay the Ken will
get a new one anyway so he uh we uh we
used to go and uh and he'd bark and my
friends would go let's go you know yell
at him and he'd bark and I'd be like
yeah let's go yeah wait a second it's my
dog and um
and then we didn't have anything once he
oh yeah he died on a I was walking with
my dad and he had a heart attack and
died he probably froze to death and uh
notices in the summer it was just too
hot well you just watch your dog just
fall out and die yeah and my dad was
like uh I remember like what happens in
the 20s we were walking around the the
and and my he starts he collapsed and
he's just like and my dad's like oh no
and then uh another dad was like walking
and he was like oh oh my my dad goes run
home and uh tell your mom there's a
problem with Bruno and uh and I ran home
and then I never saw him again and then
uh dad to the dog uh my dad he was uh he
yeah he married uh he married that man
it was legal yeah before it was here
yeah yeah and uh anyway so that we
didn't have any pets oh yeah and a tough
year but my grandpa died and and I was
like oh Jesus everyone's dying anyway
Kanye was the same thing anyway
um he had a heart attack yeah he's
walking around yeah
you need a radio you know did you hit a
teens transistor radio for playing rock
music
[Laughter]
anyway so he uh
so we didn't have any cat we didn't have
anything until we found a cat uh in the
woods uh deaf white cat
and um
and
uh yeah and we had it because he just
wouldn't yeah you didn't figure it out
after a while yeah oh because here's the
thing so
[Music]
[ __ ] weirdo with this maniac's
clicking away
he's not gonna feed me
um yeah but anyway so he just would uh I
remember he would just
sleep in the middle of the road because
it was hot and then I look out my my
bedroom window he was like an outdoor
cat which he should not have been sure
and I watched cars pull up and like honk
and he wouldn't move
and I'd be like come on George George
please there's a car and then the guy to
get out and like stomp on the Ground
Georgia what the [ __ ] run away
my mother would not change your name
because I quote no man owns me really
yeah yeah yeah okay Hudak yeah no no
hyphenated names she agrees that those
are stupid yeah so if you have a
hyphenated name wait what was your dad's
last name or what's your dad's last name
k k yeah but your mom would use K Hudak
it wouldn't be Hudak she's just who that
she kept her name nothing nothing
changes yeah yeah okay she's not she's
not a slave that's what my mother would
say no man owns me
yeah she's a she's a very uh intense
person when I was a kid I was playing on
the street and she just ran out on the
street and she's like Graham come here I
was like what I'm playing with tennis
balls should come here and uh I go what
she goes I was like maybe 10 11. she
goes Graham she's not beside me and goes
I don't ever want to catch you in a
mosque a synagogue or a goddamn Church
before you're 18 because I don't want
those racist sexist homophobic bastards
brainwashing you and I was like all
right try a couple decafs yeah Jesus she
would always I don't know she must have
seen something by the way the cat got
ran over yeah he did uh yeah of course
yeah yeah sleeping in the middle of the
street yeah I think it was a skydiving
we'd be like watching TV and then some
lady with like this local six o'clock
news and some lady would come on and be
like her daughter died or whatever and
then she'd be like
you know the only thing keeping me
together is knowing that one day I'll
see you again in heaven I just hear my
mom behind me go [ __ ] lunatic
chill out
she's hard notes yeah yeah [ __ ]
lunatic is she still working for the
post office or she retired she retired
so she's tired yeah vice president yeah
well one step below vice president which
there are many of those sure but still
pop brass still yeah yeah awesome or a
suit had an office I had a secretary
yeah yeah yeah
huh anybody any any of the of the family
ever spot a UFO up there have you ever
think you've seen a UFO I feel like it'd
be right up your alley uh no I never saw
a UFO no never even seen the Northern
Lights really yeah huh interesting I'm
not even sure what they are from being
Alice
yeah I just don't know it do your
parents still live in the same house
uh no they they they moved and then uh
yuppies bought it and I was always like
maybe I'll one day I'll be a famous
comedian I'm not gonna be like let me
show you I used to live here you know
what I mean and they uh
they gutted it they they you're by a
City log it's an old house so you have
to keep the three three out Outer walls
okay and then they just tore everything
down in the middle and completely
different house yeah facade yeah what
was the name of that street melgand
avenue melgen Avenue yeah that's pretty
nice yeah how about the name of the
grocery store where your mom shop IGA
and IGA is in bed go to the IGA I don't
go there the IGA hmm okay do you ever
have a Chia Pet growing up
yeah well there was an unused Chia Pet
on the top of the kitchen cabinet I
always thought it was cool was it in a
box or was it just out of the box I
think my mom thought it was cool to like
like uh a little I don't know drink it
yeah Pottery type thing I never grew it
the Chia was it the sheep or whatever
was it the guy was it was it or the
traditional is that chia seeds by the
way is that what it is good question oh
probably wow that's wild talk about
ahead of their time I think it's a
little yeah it's a little too far
Advanced no I think it's the right
amount of garbage to have a Chia and not
know what sure there you go uh I I think
uh anyway yeah I don't know it was like
a little horse thing yeah yeah
um what was the name of your pizza place
in your town
oh you guys eat Boston Pizza is not a
big thing we have our own kind of pizza
and they don't even know they have their
own kind of pizza they just made
American Pizza bad and it became in
their own pizza gotcha uh lay it on us
what is it it's just very doughy Pizza
with a lot of sauce and then all of the
toppings on top of the sauce
like the vegetables and the the meat or
whatever and then the thick layer of
cheese on top and so everything is just
wet and boiled underneath it like no no
crispy pepperonis none of that sounds
appetizing yeah I don't know
pizza with Albert's Pizza or something
and it came it came with a bun in the
middle wow which I liked we always yeah
so the pizza box wouldn't crush it you
know you know little tables you didn't
have that well it was it was a little it
was like their signature was like a
little little roll in the middle wow
I actually I think that's good I can get
behind that's yeah real and we would
fight for the roll in the middle even
though it's just plain bread yeah no
that's fine I can totally see that we
used to fight when we were kids for if
you had the pizza no there was always uh
there was always one big bubble like
like a rust blister like you had on the
top yeah yeah there was always one of
those you always wanted to slice that I
had that yeah and you rip that open
that's fun it's crispy that's all right
then I like that Chinese was a Chinese
spot up there did you do Chinese
yeah the the whole ah man I it's been so
long since I lived in Ottawa it's like
it bothers me I can't remember the pizza
place and I think it was like
the whole my
it was like the first one I remember my
dad we'd go there because my dad went
there because it was the first Chinese
place in like 1971 or 68 or something
and they were like what the hell
is coming that isn't boiled ham
dear Lord
[Laughter]
yeah okay uh yeah it was just like a
generic like ho ho or something you know
one of those
yeah they closed down what was the last
time you were on a boat and where was it
I got fired from a cruise ship like like
uh like I'm like two months ago what
well whoa yeah you want to talk about
that sure I got I uh yeah I've been
fired I've done three cruise ships in
the past six months but I got fired from
two of them what happened hey you're
you're pretty clean yeah super clean
super fun yeah but here's the thing is
like I will I refused in my head I'm
like I don't want to become a boat act
sure so you're just doing your action
yes I've told myself when I started
doing it when I started doing it like I
really needed the money so I was just
doing you know old hits you know what I
mean and like trying to survive or
whatever and and then I was like I felt
like
maybe I'm being an idiot but I was like
I'm just gonna do my ACT I'm and if they
if they tell me not to swear I won't
swear tell me not to do this I mean it's
a contract straight up the middle funny
it's all thank you but they so I have a
joke about uh I touch on I mentioned my
brother that has autism I'm not making
fun of him I love him very much it's
making fun of me and I have another joke
about how my grandfather my mother's
father and my mother's mother hid Jewish
people in World War II in Prague Czech
Slovakia and they I got fired because
too many people complained that I talked
about Nazis I mentioned Nazis and
complained that I was talking about
autism and like I like my grand my
grandson has autism and he shouldn't be
making fun of these boats and um and so
it's just you really have you can't be
you know it's like I do I I do okay on
cruise ships that have I don't you know
I only do like a few a year just to you
know or take the edge off sure you know
um but you you know it's it's a fine
balance you don't want to become you can
get stuck on them if you start playing
to them you're like that's the right
mentality of like hey yeah this is a
[ __ ] good paycheck I can go do my
[ __ ] do my ACT there and [ __ ] do
it you know and get out that's right
mentality people get addicted to the
paycheck and they're like the paycheck
and then you become you become a boat
act like they'll tell me like it's
always me and also you never can have a
sustainable relationship because 14 days
at a time you're at Sea they would like
there's all I was it's you're usually
paired with another comic it was always
me and a 58 year old man going through a
divorce everyone I've met everyone every
you know yeah not to throw the name but
bodak you know people I know where I'm
gonna end up yeah a couple of years I
mean they're making like a hundred and
like six figures a year yeah they own a
condo in Florida it's always in Florida
yeah like I haven't been there in six
months yeah homeowners associations
sending me letters yeah the windows are
smashed yeah
it's always [ __ ] like that it's always
um
he's like I have a land gig coming up
yes and I was like that's a gig it's not
like you're you're
darling water game you're doing water a
land gig it's just just a gig yeah I
heard that right I think in the first or
second cruise I heard that I was like oh
boy oh Grandma you gotta you gotta watch
yourself out here
but like there are some funny comics
doing it sure uh they're all like nice
people and if and it's like I get it you
like reach a level in comedy you've been
you're like
40 whatever 50 whatever you're like I
can't live hand to mouth anymore it's
that I also think the the the the art
form of it at some age you stop
progressing when you get into your 50s
yeah you're not like unless you're like
in the club unless you're eddiepapitone
exactly it was like a shout out to Daddy
yeah you stop progressing so it's like
hey I'm doing my act that I was doing
for the past 20 years these are the
people that enjoy those like that's
where those people are yeah yeah like
you're not gonna Bend well with the
seller or the comedy stores right where
were you maybe my people will be when
I'm there when when they're of cruise
age but you know maybe you know where
were you when you got fired like
physically uh they can walk the plank or
something uh I was in my uh my room the
room they gave me on the boat my
stateroom they're not good right I hear
I hear they put them in the worst I'm
I've I've only done good cruise lines
that give you like a good room that they
would give the customers when I get ones
with a window pretty sick nice uh like
the food's really good the room
yeah it's like if you can get one with a
comedy club on it it's all right you
know
um you know it's a lot you have to have
like a lot of time like so so they come
down and they say hey Graham you're out
well I I was supposed to do uh
I was supposed to do it was New Jersey
to uh the Bahamas I was gonna say it
leaves New Jersey and goes straight to
the Bahamas okay and not the Bahamas the
other one Bermuda Bermuda the one that's
closer and then you go then they spend
three days there and then they go
straight back it's a week long and um
and then I was supposed to do two of
those and on the way back to New Jersey
I had already finished all my shows and
I was in the second leg they were like
cute the the the cruise director was
like Hey you know you want to like help
me out with this like you know stupid
game show obviously no but you say yes
sure and um you know once some weird
game they do on stage or whatever
um but I uh I I called him I was like
hey you still want me to do the game
show he's like nah you're fired and it
was the same guy that fired me two ships
ago
same guy he just didn't like me yeah but
then he asked you to help and then but
then he fires you he forgot about me the
second one it's the second time I've
been fired and I just I just showed up
and then the guy forgot
by the way well why are they fire you
did they have like a reason of like he
cursed or your little oh I'm sorry they
said they said too many people were
complaining about uh talking about World
War II and Nazis and uh so you're on
your way back to Jersey at this point so
you just got off when you just got off
uh yeah I got off yeah man
yeah like escort you off the ship or
anything like that you just leave it no
I'm not a pedophile
put me off the ship
[Laughter]
[Music]
wild yeah all right I mean I I feel I
got a couple more I feel like we got
them pretty dead the rights I'll do it
yeah the story was why we didn't get to
that many questions
I like it it's a good thing though have
you ever owned any Hard Rock t-shirts
yeah yeah like the Hard Rock Cafe
T-shirt oh yes when I was a kid I tried
I collected them my mom would always buy
one whenever she went but they went on a
vacation neighbor oh I got you one uh
where'd you go mom Vermont yeah
Notch
we got one shot up to the Hard Rock and
Saskatchewan yeah oh buddy I I uh
definitely had Montreal yeah definitely
had Toronto that's funny
um when was the first time you had
Lobster
yeah something I got well I went to
college on the east coast and I had
Lobster I think I had a McDonald's
They had a McDonald's lobster roll
pretty sweet
yeah
Diet Pepsi please yeah to wash this down
will you and your family order the same
thing at a restaurant I get the vibe
that you guys might be like if you go to
a place where you each get like the
chicken piccata or something like that
no we could order a different whatever
okay yeah yeah all right yeah could you
see Alder in the same thing um have you
ever signed up for a free trial just for
the promotion like you know
mom had to call Columbia House yeah [ __ ]
off they never did anything leave him
alone he's a good boy he does the drugs
but still I don't know he's got my Jimi
Hendrix album suckers yeah I cleaned up
on that
Fleetwood Mac do you eat ice do you chew
your ice yeah there you go absolutely
you peeing in the shower yeah not all
the time you brush your teeth in the
shower no what are you sleeping
a bed
socks so you put socks on uh
uh only in the winter my toesies are
cold yeah yeah otherwise your boxers
t-shirt I do uh boxer briefs and I do
that's it nice
all right give the people what they want
sometimes they wear a t you know last
time I wore a tea there's a cool breeze
it was nice yeah fall is here it's all
right the zapana you play any
instruments no I have a guitar that I
got uh so I could I tried to get like an
easy grade in college and it was by far
the hardest course I've ever taken and I
got like a c minus and it's still there
I still have it just look at it I'm like
one day I thought in the pandemic I'd
pick it up well no is it hanging on the
wall in your apartment it was displayed
in the living room embarrassingly and
now it's like it's tough Graham why
don't you play damn my fingers just
left-handed yeah
[Music]
um sleep with the TV on
no I have 80d I'll stay up until it
turns off I'll stay up for 10 days
straight if it's on if it's on yeah
what's the credit score like
oh it's been good it's been good lately
nice what kind of credit cards we're
talking I think we're I mean I think
we're talking 720s okay yeah solid yeah
you have an Amex I got a I got a uh I
got an Amex and I got a Visa uh like a
black one Premiere okay yeah not too
sure it's pretty good yeah but this is
all recent sure of course yeah of course
this is this is pretty getting fired
from the cruise ships
very true do you know how to tie a tie
absolutely I know I used to sell suits
whoa so I know tell us about this at
Holt rent through it's like Canada's
Macy's okay nice to sell suits at Macy's
no big deal oh hell yeah that was more
of a yeah
I was more of a resoled shoes
is so cute I was a cobbler you were in
the suit Department I was in a suit
Department I was very bad at the job and
uh when you leave it trying to pick up
on a theme here yeah I've been fired
this is true I've been fired 19 times
of course you have yeah but when I left
it when you leave that job what you do
is you get
um a client book because they're all
rich people and you try and you go Mr
Thompson you know you know Mr Thompson's
coming in and you look oh he's got two
kids a wife and you go well maybe the
wife would like this and the kid you
know you get in their phone number and
everything and it was a book back then
and um
like from like
2005 when I was doing this job till now
is just it's the 70s to the 90s it's
like crazy difference sure enough and
anyway so it was a book back then and uh
and I uh I drew I just would like I was
like [ __ ] this job and I would draw
[ __ ] in it and everything and it was
like a big joke like because you when
someone left you would want you people
would offer you money for your book and
you have to bid to be bidding Moors and
stuff and everyone just was like you
know it was like a big joke like how
much you're gonna bid on Graham's book
Because I had like like seriously like
two names of like old gay guys who'd
like oh make you try this
you want a suit though right
hey I own like four don't you ever use
late night and stuff yeah didn't you
well you do you have like a sharp blue
suit with the yeah yeah you do you have
a real shark he looks good in a suit
he's got a tall you got a big good frame
on a kid you own a tux but uh I do I
bought um I was never even gonna [ __ ]
ask
I found uh Eve sale around tucks
[Applause]
out of Value Village YSL baby
it's a Value Village is like uh uh in
Canada it's like a Salvation Army okay
and I it was like five bucks and I think
it's worth like a couple Grand oh that
doesn't count and then I bought h m
pants to go with it so yeah no you know
so you have the you don't have a tux you
have the tux jacket I have another guy's
tux jacket I have a dead man's Ducks
Jack
I mean you really let
it
talks
man the more that you talk the more the
more I got [ __ ] yeah yeah it's like
being in a relationship with me oh man
that's dark hot
cool off real quick word by word yep yep
I mean yeah I mean what were you
thinking Graham
you're [ __ ] trash kids we're sending
it a boot camp
two years baby buddy that was absolutely
fantastic loved it you're 100 trash but
we [ __ ] love you and you're one of
the funniest gang again he's got a brand
new special out Grand K live in a
bowling alley go over to YouTube Graham
K comedy and check it out I'd appreciate
that uh listener super super fun very
funny good pal of ours anything else you
got the folks out there you got coming
up follow me on Instagram Mr Graham K
I'd really appreciate that thank you so
much guys I have a present for you guys
probably I don't know what it is it's uh
you know it's I know you this is a you
know it's a trashy thing to have a uh
I got Graham K air freshener it says be
safe
that's pretty
you look like you though really
it's a guy who kind of looks like you
when you bought them at the Salvation
it's Ethan Hawk it looks like Costa a
little bit I know I got a big problem I
look like too much buddy that's
beautiful thank you so much yeah perfect
absolutely thank you what do you got for
him uh guys we are all over the road out
there uh link is in the description get
your [ __ ] tickets Atlanta we have two
shows in Atlanta the right place
Festival you can get tickets just for
that show or the whole of yeah the whole
festival if you want come see us we're
in Charlotte we're out of the show in
Rhode Island added a show in Boston
those are gonna sell out get those
tickets gang we love you see you next
week peace